I think that fundamentalists and
atheistic scientists have the same
problem,
the fundamentalists,
so we could say the Christian
fundamentalists in the US make the
proposition that biblical stories,
we'll call them mythological stories,
are literal representations of the
truth,
but,
and that might be true depending on what
you mean by literal,
but what they mean by literal over what
they attempt to make literal mean is
that they're in the same category of
scientific facts because they don't have
the idea that there are different ways
of approaching truth and the truth can
serve different purposes.
They don't have a sense that your
definition of truth is actually
something like a tool rather than an
ontological statement about the reality
of the world.
And so the.
The fundamentalists basically make the
proposition that the idea that God
created the world in six days,
5,000
years ago is literally true and they get
the 5,000
year estimate.
By the way,
by going through the genealogies in the
Old Testament and adding up the
hypothetical ages and figuring out.
You know how long before Moses Adam
lived and some bishop did that back in
the.
I think it was in the mid 18 hundreds,
I might be wrong about that,
but it was somewhere back about that
time and more or less that's been
accepted as canonical fact ever since,
and then the scientists say,
well,
yeah,
those are empirical truth.
They're just wrong.
See,
and that's the only difference there is
between the fundamentalists and the
atheist scientists,
the fundamental say those are
fundamental scientific truths and
they're right and the scientists say,
well,
their scientific truths,
they just happened to be wrong.
Well,
I think that's a stupid argument
personally.
I mean for a bunch of reasons.
One is that the people who wrote the,
the ancient stories that we have access
to,
we're in no way shape or form
scientists,
you know,
modern people tend to think that you
think like a scientist and people have
always thought that way.
First of all,
you do not think like a scientist.
Even scientists hardly even think like
scientists,
but if you're not scientifically
trained,
you don't think like a scientist at all.
So one of the things,
for example,
that characterizes your thinking is
confirmation bias.
And so if you have a theory,
what you do is wander around in the
world looking for reasons why it's true,
and the scientists does exactly the
opposite of that in the little tiny,
narrow domain where he or she is
actually capable of being a scientist
and what they have is a theory and
looked for a way to prove it wrong.
But believe me,
you don't run around doing that.
I mean you,
you can train yourself so now and then
you can do that,
you know,
we can learn to listen to people,
for example,
on the off chance that you might be
wrong,
but that is by no means a natural way of
thinking.
And of course the,
the,
the fundamental philosophical axioms of
the scientific method weren't developed
until descartes and,
and who else?
Descartes.
Bacon is one more.
Anyways,
the name escapes me at the moment,
but you can argue about when science
emerged,
but you,
you,
it certainly emerged in it's articulated
form within the last thousand years.
I think you could say even more
specifically that had emerged in the
last 500 years.
Now you might argue with that and say,
well,
what about the Greeks and other people
who were fairly technologically
sophisticated or who invented geometry
or that kind of thing,
but yeah,
yeah,
bear precursors to the idea of empirical
observation.
Aristotle,
for example,
when he was writing down his knowledge
of the world,
it never occurred to him to actually go
out in the world and look at it to see
if what he assumed about it was true and
it certainly never occurred to Aristotle
to get 20 people to go look at the same
thing independently.
Write down exactly how they went about
doing it,
compare the records,
and then extract out what was common and
that's a.
That seems self evident to us to some
degree,
but you know,
it was by no means self evident to
anyone 500 years ago and people still
don't do it.
So it's not even.
It's not plausible.
If you know anything about the history
of ideas,
it's not plausible to pause it.
That stories about the nature of reality
that existed before 500 years ago were
scientific at any but the most cursory
of ways.
So why we have that argument continually
somewhat beyond me.
Part of the reason is though that
everyone fundamentalists included really
believe in scientific facts.
Even though they hate it,
they'll use computers,
they'll fly,
computers won't work,
wouldn't work unless quantum mechanics
were correct,
like the fact that you use a high tech
device indicates through your action
that you actually accept the theories
upon which is predicated,
right?
Same as flying the same as anything you
do in it too.
Complex Technological Society,
you're stuck with it.
You're reading by the lights.
Do they work?
Yeah,
they work well,
so it's really hard for people who are
trying to hold onto a way of looking at
the world that appears to contradict the
scientific claims when everything they
do is predicated on their acceptance of
the validity of the scientific claims.
It's really problematic for people and
it's problematic in a real way,
I think because one of the problems with
the scientific viewpoint is it doesn't
tell you anything about what you should
do with your life.
It doesn't.
It doesn't solve the problem of value at
all.
In fact,
it might make it more difficult because
one of the fundamental scientific
claims,
roughly speaking,
is that every fact is of an equal
utility,
at least from a scientific perspective.
Right?
There is no hierarchy facts.
It's not exactly.
That's not exactly true because you can
think of one theory is more true than
another,
but that boils down to saying that it's
more useful than.
So I don't think that that's a really
good exception.
Okay,
so fine.
You got the scientific atheist,
so on one end,
and you got the religious
fundamentalists on the other and what
they both agree on whether they like it
or not,
is that there's so much power in the
scientific method that it's difficult to
dispute the validity of scientific facts
and they seem to exist in contradiction
to the older archaic stories.
If you also accept them as fast fact
based account.
So what do we do about that?
Well,
if you're on a scientific atheist end of
things,
you say,
well,
those old stories or just superstitious
science,
second rate,
barbaric archaic forms of science,
you just dispense with them.
They're nothing but trouble and if
they're on their fundamentalist side you
say,
well,
we'll try to shoe horn science into this
framework.
And really that doesn't work very well.
It doesn't work very well with the
claims of evolution.
For example,
fact it works very badly and that's a
problem because evolutionary theory is
like,
it's a killer theory and it's re,
it's,
it's really,
really hard and like it's not a complete
theory and there's lots of things we
don't know about evolution,
you know,
trying to wear hand wave that away.
That's,
that's not gonna work without dispensing
with most of biology.
So.
So that's a big problem.
So here's another way of thinking about
it.
You don't just need one way of looking
at the world.
Maybe you need two ways of looking at
the world and I'm not exactly sure how
they should be related to one another.
Like which should take precedence under
which circumstances,
but one problem is what's the world made
of,
you know,
what's the world conceptualized as an
objective place made of.
And the other is how should you conduct
yourself while you're alive?
And there's no reason to assume that
those questions can be answered using
the same approach.
I mean
physics has its methods and chemistry
has its methods and biology has its
methods,
so a method for obtaining the truth can
be bound to a domain.
So why would we necessarily assume that
you could use the same set of tools to
represent the world as a place of
objects and to represent it as a place
in which a biological creature would act
in anyways.
I'm suggesting that we,
that we don't view it that way,
that we have two different viewpoints.
Maybe they can be brought together,
although it's not obvious how,
but that it's not a tenable solution to
get rid of one in favor of the other.
And I think the reason for that is
you need to know how to conduct yourself
in the world.
You have to have a value system.
You can't even look at the damn world
without a value system.
It's not possible.
Your emotional health is dependent on a
value system.
The way you interact with other people
is dependent on a value system.
There's no getting away from it.
And you say,
well,
there's no justification for any value
system from a scientific perspective.
You're going to draw that conclusion
that no value system is valid.
Where the hell does that leave you?
There is no down,
there's no APP,
there's no rationale for moving in any
direction.
There's not even really any rationale
for living.
And so people say things like that,
well why?
Why the hell should I care what happens
in a million years?
Who's going to know the difference?
It's like,
yeah,
true,
stupid but true.
And the reason I think it's stupid is
because it's just a game,
you know,
I can take anything of any sort,
can find a context in which it's
irrelevant.
It's just a rational games like who
cares if a hundred children freeze to
death in a blizzard,
who,
what difference is going to make a
billion years?
Well,
what do you say to someone who says that
you say,
well,
seems like the wrong frame of Reference
Bucko.
That's what it looks like to me.
You know,
because at some point you question the
dam frame of reference,
not what you derive from it.
And it certainly seems to me that
situations like that don't allow you to
use that kind of frame of reference.
There's something inhumane about it and
that trumps the logic,
or at least it should.
And if it doesn't,
then all hell breaks loose.
And that doesn't seem to be a good
thing.